speaking of gaslighting there is a
terrible event occurred a couple days
ago we did we did not get to it on the
show yesterday
this was this terrible shooting in
colorado 10 people were killed
in a grocery store and a shooting in
boulder colorado after a man walked in
to king super's store and opened fire
and before you heard any details
about this shooting you saw prominent
left-wingers tweeting posting commenting
about the perils of white supremacy and
how this is
just more evidence that evil white
americans
need to i don't know have their
liberties curtailed or or need to be
dealt with as a public health problem
and then then it turned out it was
not white supremacy the shooter's name
we have a policy at the daily wire where
we
we do not say the shooter's name so i
won't say the full name
uh the first name is ahmad so
[Music]
you know use your mind from there it's
not like john smith okay it's not it's
not a name you would associate
with uh say white supremacy uh actually
this this guy was a syrian immigrant
his family came here in 2002 he's not
christian we
we hear this talk about christian
nationalism now this is another
silly phrase that's being conflated with
white supremacy
uh he wasn't christian he's muslim so
now
we've gone from blaming the shooter
and everything he was going to represent
back when the liberals thought that
he was a white guy now we're talking
about the guns
and it's so it's so bigoted
it gets to something we talked about
yesterday we've talked about it several
times in the past few weeks
according to the left's racial ideology
only
white people are fully people according
to the left
actually specifically only white men
only straight white men only straight
white men who know that they're men
that narrow group those are the only
people with agency with
will and with intellect every other
group of people
is some sort of passive entity
that that is merely a victim of
whiteness and white supremacy
so when they thought it was a white guy
oh well that's his fault and
and everything that he represents when
they find out he's not a white guy
oh well we got to ban guns
or some people actually persisted we we
played a clip yesterday on the show
where some millennial gal came out and
said that
even if a racial minority perpetrates a
crime against
another racial minority that can be
part and parcel of white supremacy how
i don't know that's the premise that
they're that they're beginning with
now they're blaming the guns identity
politics actually
does have something to do with this
shooting
according to the denver post and
according to people who apparently knew
the guy
denver post very interesting article
said that
this guy hernandez who knew the shooter
said
that the shooter apparently appeared to
be paranoid about perceived slights
against him
and another person who knew the shooter
said that he was often concerned about
being targeted because of his muslim
faith
so so one of these guys says he would
talk about him being muslim and how if
anybody tried anything he would file a
hate crime and say they were making it
up
it was a crazy deal i just know he was a
pretty cool kid until something made him
mad and then whatever made him mad
he went over the edge way too far so
according to people who who knew the
shooter he
the shooter recognized that grievance
was social currency
that the racial and religious identity
politics
that now pervades our culture
could be used as a weapon could be used
as a political tool
and apparently he was rather taken with
this kind of grievance politics
the same sort of grievance politics that
had people jumping to the conclusion
based on nothing other than bigotry i
suppose or prejudice
that the shooter was a white guy but
then the minute he wasn't never mind
back to business as usual back to our
regular old identity politics and we're
supposed to pretend
that that never happened
it i think it is important to learn the
motivations of these
shootings very often they're just
completely senseless they're just some
lunatic
sometimes there is a kind of perverse
sense to them
and whenever there is a perverse sense
to these shootings
that the left thinks it can make get
some sort of advantage out of
say it was white supremacy or something
like that then they will harp on that
ad nauseam and is it actually
interesting
to try to figure it out to see what role
these ideologies play
but the minute and this is a more
frequent occurrence the minute
that the ideological underpinnings and
motivations for these crimes
in any way touch on what the left is
mainstreaming today
well then we got to forget about that
stop it we're not allowed to talk about
it we have to stay quiet
we got to talk about the guns i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you